Let's start out by looking at a scale and some weights. A scale can determine if
the weights on the left side and the right side are equal, or if one side is
heavier than the other. I've added some weights to the scale. The left side of
the scale has a total of 8 pounds. The right side of the scale also has a total
of 8 pounds. We can write an equation that represents the weight of these scales
on each side. I have 6 pounds and 2 pounds is equal to 5 pounds and 3 pounds. We
know they both make 8. Now, let's do something crazy. Let's add a ton of weight
to both sides, like 100 pounds. Think about what'd happen to the scale, and try
and answer this question. If 100 pounds of weight is added to both sides, which
side weighs the most? The left, the right, or they weigh the same.